التحول الكبيره الذي يتم من انقطاع
الطائرات الموجهه الى قطاع الطائرات ذاتيه
التوجيه يشغل بال الكثيرين من المهتمين
بصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه حول العالم
حول هذا الموضوع انضم الينا السيد شيساري
باتايا شريك فيك شركه بي دبليو سي الرائده
في قطاع الطائرات للدفاع والفضاء في
ايطاليا سيد تشي ساري اهلا بك في عسكريه
سيد شيساري في البدايه عمليه التحول التي
تتم في هذه المرحله من قطاع الطائرات
ذاتيه التوجيه من قطعه طائرات الموجهه الى
قطاع الطائرات ذاتيه اولا كيف ترى عمليه
التحول الذي تتم في هذا المجال
الحب
عمليه التحول مستمره وقد بدات منذ بضع
سنوات لم نبلغ مرحله التحول التام فهناك
اختلافات كبيره بين المنظمات الموجهه عن
بعد والموجهه ذاتيا فالاولى بمثابه
المركبه المعززه بالتكنولوجيا والتيار ليس
بداخلها ويمكن التحكم فيها عن بعد ولا
طالما كانت الطائره تتوجه بمشاركه طيار في
العمليه في المجالين العسكريين والمدني
فيما يخص اختبار الاداء الا ان العامين
الماضيين شهداء تحولا تدريجيا من الطائره
الموجهه عن بعد الى مواجهه ذاتيا وبمشاركه
شبه معدومه من الطيار فالطائره لمواجهه
ذاتيا تحدد مهمتها منذ الخطوات الاولى
سواء كانت طبيه او عسكريه او مدنيه مع
امكانيه زياده المدخلات الى الطائره من
بيئه خارجيه هذه الطائره قادره على
التاقلم مع المدخلات التي لا يمكن التنبؤ
بها خلال العمليه الاتمام مهمتها وهذه
العمليات جاريه حاليا الا ان درجه
اعتماديتها لم تصل الى المستوى الذي يسمح
باستخدامها في المجالات الشائعه ولذلك
اقتصر استخدام الطائره الموجهه ذاتيا على
السيناريوهات الهجوميه في المجال العسكري
وللحملات التجريبيه في الجانب المدني
الاعتماد على ذكاء الاصطناعي في عمليه
التحول هذه كيف ترى الاعتماد على الذكاء
الاصطناعي في ما يتم من عمليه التحول في
هذا المجال همم
الميدانيه والذكاء الاصطناعي سيساعد على
تقليص مده الاستفاده من البيانات المتعدده
او ما يسمى البيانات الكبرى ومنحي قدرات
استجابه خلال فتره زمنيه قصيره جدا وهذا
يعني ان الذكاء الاصطناعيه سيمنح المنظومه
الموجهه ذاتيا قدره الاستجابه بسرعه البشر
او حتى اسرع من البشر
يتعرض هذا القطاع له هجمات سيبرانيه على
سبيل المثال هل تعتقد بان هذا القطاع
سيكون امن في المستقبل بنسبه 100%
ولن يتعرض الى هجمات سيبرانيه على سبيل
المثال يلا همم
سيف هي امنه اذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
درجه التكنولوجيا بشكل عام اعتقد اننا يجب
ان نميز بين مستويين من الامان الاول الذي
ذكرته يخص الامن السيبراني وهنا نحن نتحدث
عن مكافحه اي تدخلات او تهديدات خارجيه
محتمله تهدف الاختطاف المنظومه الذاتيه
والامن السيبراني ضمن هذا الاطار يتقدم
بسرعه فائقه واستطيع ان اقول ان
التكنولوجيا متوفره حاليا لهذا الغرض وحتى
في حال اختطاف المنظمات التكنولوجيا
متوفره ايضا ضمن سياق العمليات الهجوميه
العسكريه لاحتواء المنظومه الذاتيه حتى
عند فقدان الاشاره من نظام تحديد الموقع
جي بي اس كما ان الناس بشكل عام يعتبرونها
امنه وكما ذكرت خلال كلمه في المؤتمر انا
لا ارى حدودا واسعه بين الاستخدامات
المدنيه كريه لذلك اعتقد اننا سنصل الى
التكنولوجيا الذاتيه بالكامل حال ما يكون
هناك قبول واسع بين الناس بشكل عام ونرى
تزايد قبولهم للمنظومه الذاتيه واعتبارها
جزءا من حياتهم اليوميه وخير مثال على ذلك
السيارات ذاتيه القياده التي كانت قبل
عشره او خمسه اعوام من دروب الخيال العلمي
واصبحت الان شائعه حتى وان لم تكن امنه
بالكامل الا اننا نستخدمها لفتره قصيره
وهذا ما قصدته عندما قلت ان هناك تقاربا
بين المجالين العسكرين
والمدنيته همم وورد
الشريف في شركه بي دبليو سي الرائده في
قطاع الطائرات والدفاع في الفضاء شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا